leute hier ist wieder eure wind wanne
ungesetzter wieder unterwegs denn ich
habe einen ausflug mit meinem bruder
geplante drohung robert lohr wurde und
dieses reiseziel hat eine ganz besondere
bedeutung für uns denn wir sind hier
sehr oft als kinder hin gefahren damals
war noch alles in ordnung und wir lebten
ein stinknormales leben und wann ein
eingeschweißtes team vielleicht bis ist
der ein jahr älter als ich und war immer
schon ein held für mich ich kann ihm
immer vertrauen und das macht ihn so
meine vertrauens mensch freut es
natürlich auch alles in ordnung aber auf
dem weg dahin gab es viele stolpersteine
wie wir als familie überwinden mussten
und die uns mehr zusammengeschweißt
haben falls es nicht will ist mein
bruder ist blind und sitzt im rollstuhl
was daran liegt dass er vor jahren einen
herzstillstand in der schule hatte und
sauerstoff hören ich kann euch jetzt
nicht die medizinischen grundlagen
erklären aber ja das ist heute sein
zustand es gibt momente in denen selbst
der vertrauens mensch nichts tun kann
egal wie sehr man es sich wünscht und
darum ist es umso wichtiger einen
vertrauensvollen versicherer wie die lvm
an seiner seite zu haben um da
einzusteigen wo es der vertrauens mensch
nicht mehr kann und ich bin der lvm auch
noch dankbar dass sie diesen schönen tag
möglich machen
ich glaube jeder weiß noch gar nicht was
ihn erwarten wird aber da soll er mir
einfach mal vertrauen und hier schreibt
mir es einmal in die kommentare wer euer
vertrauens mensch ist man ja so einiges
heute für uns geplant wir bekommen eine
führung aber ich sag mal so begrüßen wir
doch erst mal den star des tages
[Musik]
finden was uns heute schon erwartet
wir sind hier in unserem kindheit
lieblingsort
[Musik]
aber wie wurde quito eigentlich zu einem
vertrauens menschen klar verstehen wir
uns gut aber es gab situationen in
unserer gemeinsamen jugend wie mir immer
bewiesen dass ich auf ihn zählen können
[Musik]
da muss ein bisschen trockener wird und
zwar fange erst mit einem darauf zugehen
die rampe
verbrechen sind zum teil relativ
freundlich so dass man die sogar
anfassen kann und ich will es mal so ein
treffer aus
die zusammen 14 treppchen drin wohnen
ich habe jetzt mal unseren
freundlichsten herausgesucht mit ins
bett denn
er tut ja
es gab man einen abend da ist mein
bruder auf eine party gegangen er wusste
dass ich keine verabredung hatte und
traurig war da keiner zeit hatte für
mich an dem abend ist quito irgendwann
nach hause gekommen und hatte gefragt ob
ich mit ihm gehen möchte mir war das
unangenehm dass er mich abholte weil ich
allein war aber er tat es ab und sagte
ach quatsch ich habe den anderen erzählt
dass ich was zu hause vergessen habe und
jetzt bist du halt spontan mit gekommen
alles was die so
etwas anderes
hier bisher total neugierig und
tatsächlich liefen die schnäppchen gar
nicht so schlimm wenn man die müssen
ganz toll aber so als
gerade
schüler sowie lassen jetzt ein bisschen
schlafen
hier ist auch schön zu machen wir und
nicht dann in einer halben stunde
wenn ich an vertrauen denke fällt es mir
manchmal schwer zu akzeptieren dass ich
nichts für ihn machen konnte als er sein
unfall hatte zu vertrauen gehört
irgendwo auf beantwortung aber manche
situationen sind einfach zu groß und der
einzelne mensch zu klein trotzdem konnte
guido immer darauf vertrauen dass ich im
krankenhaus besuchte und seine hand
hielt bestand manchmal nur da und habe
ich von meinem tag erzählt
das hat so groß
dass bleiben immer auf den kopf das ist
eine waffe zum verteidigen tatsächlich
nur und die braucht man halt immer ob
und das ist tatsächlich etwas was jedes
jahr auch ein kleines stückchen größer
wird die horner wachsen ein leben lang
solange das tier lebt und dass frauen
immer größer das ist eigentlich so was
sie unsere fingernägel also ganz harter
haut
die trockenperiode
[Musik]
die wege von fuchs und nebenan wohnt
auch noch eine dame man sieht jetzt
gerade zwei fixe hier stehen einen
schweizer pass erhalten und keinen raum
weil es keine rotfüchse sondern der mut
der straße ist ein silberfuchs und wolle
der graue ist platin november punkt
nennt man das und haben vom fuchs gockel
und damit man mal so ein eindruck
bekommt die konnte man die echten für
sie gar nicht anfassen bereich sich die
schüler habe ich hier ein
okay das ist also der fonds üblich das
ist nur ein fuchs
okay okay
der fuchsschwanz ja und hier
[Musik]
sie wolle eigentlich ne mir wurde vom
tower
ein stückchen weiter
keine bericht unterschrieben bis jetzt
gefällt mir die führung ganz gut ich
glaube quito hat auch spaß verschiedene
fälle zu berühren ist natürlich toll wir
machen hier nämlich gerade die handicap
führung das heißt alle wege sind
barrierefrei und man kann mit seinen
anderen sinnen als sehen oder
sehen dinge erleben also fühlen das
zurück
eines tages kido lag noch im wachkoma da
kam meine mutter nach hause und erzählte
davon dass er gelächelt hätte meine
schwester und ich konnte es kaum glauben
und waren super aufgeregt für den
nächsten besuchstage starten ihn an aber
nichts kein lächeln keine regung also
tat ich das was jede gute schwester tut
ich erzählte einen witz nach dem anderen
und mein bruder brach im lautlosen
gelächter aus er hatte damals ein
schlauch als deswegen kam kein ton aber
das braucht mir nicht den ausdruck in
seinem gesicht werde ich nie wieder
vergessen
für den finger können die schon würden
aber mehr schaffen sie auch nicht ab
tausend häuser
[Musik]
du bist eine inspiration für viele
tausend menschen da draußen
sind gut damit gebracht hatte nämlich
alle ganz aufgeregt und werden dazu die
sonne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
o
vor einiger zeit hatte ich ja wieder mit
angstzuständen zu kämpfen und quito hat
mich zu dieser zeit wieder komplett
überrascht er hat ganz ehrlich und offen
zu mir gesagt dass ich einfach mal einen
gang runterschalten firma auf zu viel zu
arbeiten und da hatte ich wieder gedacht
ja der weiseste mensch den ich kenne ist
mein bruder und
mein kopf wird liegen
[Musik]
dabei war
wie
das wetter auf die mal die butter aus
dem handel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
warum mussten
[Musik]
verdienen
oder man greift
[Musik]
der freund
aber so
kutscher für
die waren schon getragen
[Musik]
da stehen
du kommst nicht
[Musik]
kreativ
also kilos glücklich
oder wenn sie
[Musik]
oh ja
zu machen
[Musik]
kiefer vergab machst du marshall mit ihr
da geht dann kann man ja
[Musik]
du bist ja mein vertrauens mensch ja
heute musst du mir aber vertraut
naja
und dann genau richtig genau an habe ich
sein vertrauen gewonnen ja
[Musik]
sagen
zurück ins studio
kamera aus für diese momente wenn ich
einfach dankbar und ich hoffe das kino
und ich noch viele weitere solcher
momente haben weil er wirklich er ist
nicht nur mein vertrauens mensch ist
würde ich mein herzens mensch ich habe
das gefühl seit wir kinder sind sind wir
einen seele und ein herz und ich möchte
einfach nur dass es ihm gut geht also
quito falls du das nicht gerade hörst
ich hab dich lieb bis bald wir sehen uns
bestimmt ganz schnell wieder
und für alle anderen die das jetzt
gesehen haben ich hoffe euch hat es
gefallen
[Musik]